joining us on the line is David Limbaugh
he's author of the brand new book guilty
by reason of insanity already zooming up
the bestseller charts David great to
talk to you man thanks for having me on
you bet so what's the thesis of the book
obviously the Democrats are in the midst
of a collective insane bout but what
exactly is the thesis just bottom line
is they've gone over the deep end
far less extremism would if they had
their way if they regain control of the
major political branches the living
executive branches I believe they will
turn America into something the framers
could not have possibly envisioned and
your kids and my kids will not live in
an America that resembles anything that
we inherited from our parents so where
is all of this coming from it's been
obvious for years obviously been
covering this stuff for decades ever
since the Clinton ministration but the
left is moving left but there does seem
that that at some point there was a
full-on break from reality for a lot of
folks on the on the left and that that
has taken over the Democratic Party I
mean by contrast with Barack Obama these
people even appear to be far left yes
however he seems to enable them I I kind
of think that I saw it through this a
lot and one Seminole or pivotal event to
me is when he finally came out of the
closet figuratively speaking and said
that he now after having pretended to be
ambivalent about same-sex marriage he's
now wholeheartedly for it and all of a
sudden if you noticed even though the
public didn't really support it even in
referenda up until that time now all of
a sudden it was overnight everyone
believed that no one dared say anything
else and that seemed uh sure in a new
period of extremism he also introduced
socialism Lite with Obamacare he made
these things thinkable and doable with
American politics in ways that they
hadn't been done before and I of course
I go into how FDR and LBJ introduced
socialism themselves but this was a more
a bolder introduction and I think now
Democrats with their rabid base are also
involved in to come out and be more
Broll anymore radical and now it's
almost like they're feeding off each
other in a frenzied state and their base
is driving it and they're in an echo
chamber and they're demonstrating
themselves to be more and more radical I
can't put my finger on those are just
some things that I thought have occurred
to me about the about the turn so so
looking at the Democratic field there is
this bizarre gap right now in which Joe
Biden is is leading in in the national
polls the person who has of course the
media's adoration is Elizabeth Warren
followed closely by Bernie Sanders it
seems like by polling data a lot of
Democrats particularly the media middle
of the country are really off put by the
radical left ISM of the Democratic Party
including on on some of the more radical
social issues but they simply have no
place to turn they're turning to Joe
Biden and Biden is just too weak a
candidate to support them so where do
you think the Democratic Party is going
in do you see any hope inside the
Democratic Party for a base that is
rejecting some of the more overtly
extreme policies pursued by their
candidates well I agree with you that
Biden is weak and I think increasingly
incompetent and feeble and also will
just say whatever he needs to say to
make himself more palatable to the left
demagogue chameleon EE he's going
nowhere however he's much saner than the
rest of them on paper you know that's
why he's got a plurality I think but but
I think Warren would be the head right
now but I think it's so weak there's
someone like Bloomberg Hillary Clinton
not Hillary I don't think Hillary
because she's too feeble physically when
they tried to cover that up but I could
see Michelle Obama coming out of the
wood or that she's the one that really
scares me but I I cannot imagine this
crop of Democrats being as crazy as they
are
but one thing I will tell you and I
don't know your experience I have my law
partners or Democrats really good people
we live in the Midwest in the you know
County that is overwhelmingly Republican
and yet these Democrats who don't
subscribe to those values I guarantee
you every one of them will vote for a
Democratic candidate no matter how
radical and and that's a curious
phenomenon they're going to vote for him
anyway and so they say well they're not
that radical but
practical matter they might as well be
because they will vote for most of them
well well well David do you think that
that's a referendum on just how much
Democrats hate Republicans at this point
is this just a reaction to Trump in
other words how much of this is
authentically driven by radical
priorities and how much of this is
driven by hatred of Trump and from
arrangment syndrome okay
that's really a good question because
you put a different spin on it that I
thought well I have considered when I'm
answering this question interviews I've
done a lot of thinking about this I
don't think it's just Trump I think that
the left the media academia has
indoctrinated the rank-and-file Democrat
and minorities into believing that
conservatives are evil you look at the
polls
we're considered by an overwhelming
majority of blacks to be racist we are
now it makes it easier for them because
Trump is a border Hawk and he can be
easily associated with racism in that
sense because they attribute that to
racism when it isn't and they also have
fully convinced and they've been working
on this for decades they've convinced
Democrats that conservatives are evil
not just racist but evil uncompassionate
and capitalism it's not that socialism
is great it's that capitalism is evil
and Catholics are evil that's by the way
I think account for the rabid
anti-semitism on the left
why ket because capitalism is the
greatest people Jews are perceived to be
capitalist and so that I think that's
the logical nexus there